damit habe ich nicht gerechnet da geht's
dir wie mir ich weiß du willst ich will
nein ich werde jetzt nach hause gehen
und total schön träumen
felix das geht mir alles ein bisschen zu
schnell wenn wir erstmal das projekt
abgeschlossen haben wir lassen es
langsam angehen
versprochen
es gab irgendwie nie die gelegenheit das
tier zu erzählen und was ist so schwer
an
so ist meine ex freundin
ich fass es nicht was willst du mir noch
ich hielt es nicht für so wichtig bitte
tu mir einen gefallen und ihn nach bevor
er den mund aufmacht nicht so wichtig es
hat keine bedeutung
für dich vielleicht nicht aber ich hasse
vetternwirtschaft und du weißt genau wie
sehr ich unter meinem namen leider alle
kennen brückmann alex events in der zeit
führend auf dem markt deswegen dort etwa
dass sie ausgewählt und erdig empfohlen
aber trotzdem ist ein arbeit so
überragend dass niemand anderes in frage
kommen die hör doch auf die etwas
vorzumachen
bist du was und verlogen
ich bin weg gefragt ob ich lust hätte
noch eine runde mit ihm im holunder zu
kickern ihr braucht nicht auf mich
warten kommen nicht zu spät nach hause
also das handy dabei kümmere dich mal
lieber meine zukünftige schwägerin
es tut mir leid dass ich dir das nicht
gleich gesagt haben
mir tut es leid dass ich mich so
verhalten
so ein zufall gibt es schon mal öfter
als man denkt ich werde mich mit diesem
thema so dumm anstellen lässt dann nur
besser werden kann hier eine gute idee
frau schäfer eine weinschorle so
warte ich zeig dir hast du da noch mal
gesehen
ja ich habe eine wärmflasche gemacht sie
hatte schmerzen im unterleib wollen aber
alles nicht so schlimm
woher willst du das so genau wissen ich
hab's gegoogelt
das gehört dazu wenn ein kind erwartet
wird auf allen seiten in allen foren im
internet zum thema könnte auch bei
schwangerschaft schwangerschaft es aber
keinen spaß
da muss man aufpassen warum hast du so
gut darüber bescheid
ich bin eine frau übersehen